Maron Kagame is a fabulous comedian he's
of Iranian descent he lived in London
Turkey and Boston and all over the place
in the but somebody here he is welcome
yes you are welcome irani welcoming
we're happy you're here I'm happy to be
here thank you so much for having me
beautiful people of course you come in
like a ball of energy that it's the
coffee it is and we've never interacted
before other than at the cellar we bump
into each other and we did that that
kind of sit around documentary with with
[ __ ] with Christina we did with
Christina Hutchinson yeah was the
documentary on good [ __ ] what yeah what
is that about
about a prostitute woman who is also a
comedian who goes by the name of Wendy
star yeah her documentary yeah oh that's
right yes that's going to Wendy's done
yeah so Wendy I think at some point came
across some kind of billionaire because
she keeps I swear I'm not on coke I
swear to god it's okay if you are no I
would tell you if I were on god sheriff
I romka okay and the someone took some
kind of interest in her this was like
three years ago when I met her and she
was on a bunch of coke and then and then
she's mentioned that someone was making
a documentary about her and here we are
three years later she was in Luzon was
she or not last Monday well sometimes
she's a fun girl yeah she is I was
hoping we were finally gonna get a
documentary where it uncovers the fact
that a lot of comedians while they're
funny on stage are sad and realize we
did kind of end up getting talked about
like watching people burned alive in
[ __ ]
yeah oh yeah we talked beheading video
you are a beheading video fan I have to
see everything cuz I'm from Iran I lived
in Iran you're a head of the iran-iraq
war so I saw my first limit 9 yes it was
like it was a leftover limb it was a
limb of a but do we know what limit was
a leg arm we don't know she's knows it
all right okay and so ever since then I
have to see like the most gruesome thing
like if I hear there's a car accident I
have to see the pieces it's Who I am
it does Jade you though it makes you
weirdly like disc it makes you like
desensitize to it yeah then you'll see
one that resets it like one will be
bad you like oh my god I can't go down
this road that actually just happened to
me that's when you have to get out and
say no more
this most recent season of narcos I was
just watching it with the FBI agent what
Camarena
yes Kiki marina sure ed they tortured
him for like 30 hours yeah and so this
is the sick part is that if I'm watching
it on on the screen and I know it's
supposed to go down a certain way I'll
be like it didn't happen like that or it
would be it would be more gruesome than
that people pop like grapes so I had to
look up and actually read what happened
to him and that went too far when I read
just reading it just real what story yes
what do they do them that was so bad the
worst part which I had never heard
before is that it kept him awake on meth
so where normally people would pass out
yeah from the intensity of the torture
they kept him alive on meth so that he
was up for thirty hours getting tortured
oh my it's completely that yes the math
because I've done I when I was younger
much much younger and sinner I I did a
bunch of I used to do a bunch of meth
and I believe I know that you would stay
awake through torture it's a mess that's
a mess what were they torturing him with
drills roll through his hand or
something broke through his hand and
head oh you're like crushed so you're
like I've been on meth before I know
that on met the last thing I want to do
is have drills put into my body or maybe
the first so is that how you desensitize
yourself when you're a kid you're kind
of like this is the reality that I live
in
you just have to disconnect from it and
just what make it all in so you're not
that is reality right that's reality
like other [ __ ] you know like Nic Cage
movie you know him like not reality limb
reality right you know car accident
reality motorcycle accident those are
the best videos by the way motorcycle
you like those I know I don't like him
but I watch him because those are ones
that could happen like I won't watch the
beheadings anymore or the murders but in
a car accident is a feasible way to die
and like I could see that happening yeah
so that just reminds me to be traffics
more
this like it reaffirms one's fear of
heights what happens when people fall
for my Jesus right you know what I mean
right so yeah when you see somebody
that's like hanging on and you're like
in that moment he thought he might pull
himself back up and then the hands just
slip yeah but he really thought he was
gonna get back up I do I do pull-ups in
the gym and I always thought I've seen
footage of guys gripping something and
falling but I'll do pull-ups and I'll
think of that and getting yourself in a
pull-up all over is is I couldn't do it
I couldn't get on even I can do a
pull-up like it doesn't matter I could
not host my body weight up onto a thing
if I was dying with my rehearse falling
I rehearse let losing my grip
and then ah it's drama it's a mostly at
the gym for drama I see that makes sense
so I mean your parents had to be very
proud you know you you come out as a gay
man you start doing math you see you do
all this stuff you're conservative
Iranian parents must have been like oh
we were hoping we would have a gay son
the dude man yeah I lost I did I lost my
parents unfortunately not in the fire no
but they lost that they stopped tracking
means somewhere on 15 so you do not have
a relationship with them at all no now I
do but it's almost like you know it's we
kind of haunt each other you know it's
like two ghosts passing in the night
right it's not a it's not like a good
flesh and blood relationship you know
it's it's bizarre the people have you
you kind of only get one chance to like
to really fail your your kids or your
parents you really only get one chance
and then after that it's sort of do they
live there or no here no they're here
what dad's dead thank God I swear to God
there was no better feeling than when my
dad died didn't have this feeling and I
know a lot of people love their parents
but I my father there was like this
oppressive so long as he walked this
earth I felt like he was he had some
kind of influence on my life and when he
died I was like I like I it felt like a
literal weight was lifted off my
shoulders well I was reading about your
story about when you came out to him Wow
and and the advice that he gave you was
suicide actually yeah yeah yeah he told
me to kill myself at 15 yeah how did you
come out to him I just told him I was
dad I think I'm bisexual which I like I
lied to everyone about the bisexual
thing it was never gonna happen it was
just a it's been a motorway like a
Blanding strip of dicks 25 26 years
Dixon Dixon dick have you got to go I
ate a girl's [ __ ] out because she
bought me stole the orange it was like a
long I was the coke man Miami so did you
wanted you want ended it was an [ __ ]
I really just directed lips but you
wanted him to believe like oh no I might
like girls a little bit increases your
street cred like if you can go to the
walk the mean streets of Chinatown now
gays are more interested in you yeah
they know that you might not stick
around Yeah right yeah exactly so he can
do that it's almost like a quien s
massager it's like when people eat
cockroaches for Rogen do you know what I
mean they're just trying to get his
pants yeah yeah that makes sense that
makes sense
so but you figure if you tell your dad
you're bisexual
at least he might think he might not be
as disappointed completely withdraw you
know what I mean like what you were
incorrect yeah I was completely wrong
and then so my father was a
neuropsychiatrist his clinic was the
bottom floor of our house growing up and
he used to because my dad grew up hyper
poor he did a lot of pro bono work so he
had villagers illiterate villagers from
all around Iran who would bring their
their kids and themselves into his
office he had one villager family who
they brought their son they were like
he's gay my dad's like I don't have a
therapy for this there's no drug for
this he just has to abstain they came
back two months later they were like he
killed himself so there was no thought
in your dad's mind of he could just live
it's okay and I'm like and also that's
not true culturally like if three men of
repute accuse you of homosexuality you
now stand on trial for homosexuality and
the outcomes are death mm-hmm
repentance in prison or forced mandatory
sex change Wow trans people over there
if you if you get a sex change and
you're trans you're okay you are now a
heterosexual female you're not a
homosexual so they don't but they're not
even trans though they're not enforced
like there are stories and stories of
stories of people who wish that they
didn't have their decks chopped off
surprise yeah I can see that being high
on the wish list now by the way that
would explain why some of the other
limbs that you saw just out out on the
street later in life that's you have no
idea how so the kid killed himself so
the kid kills himself and then my dad
said well it was for the best he did and
that was the story my father told me
instantly like I was like dad I think
I'm I like dudes and he was like let me
tell you something that's were the best
yeah he wanted you to kill yourself
suicide is for the best yeah and he's
like a master manipulator I mean he's a
super psychiatrist he's trained so many
people all around the world so did he
believe that that he actually believed
that himself though I think yeah I think
he would have liked but then here's the
things after he died I found all these
pictures of him and like on the beach
and like the South of France and it's
like just him and muscular dudes not a
woman to be found and it's all pictures
of just the dudes Wow
picture of like you know a sweet friends
do you think he might have had an
inclination or I mean most guys end up
experimenting not me not to be great not
an Sam I haven't experimented myself
right so yet ya know that yeah the day
is young I just the morning I have been
under more [ __ ] grandest than futon
mattress it's unbelievable I how many
times I've been the experiment T right
you don't mind that I loved it not be my
favorite thing was being with straight
dudes that's scary to be in a ran doing
that dough and they [ __ ] and when
they'll kill you for it but I that's the
thing is I do when I was really at the
height of it I was the scarier party
what do you like and no I I would
specifically go out and look for someone
who scared me and invariably scare them
I was a super drinker like I was a
fighter we aggressive I could be
aggressive I could fight but I didn't
like that was last resort so you lived
in Iran for how long what ages where
zero to three nine to eleven okay so you
kind of you don't come out in Iran but
at eleven do you kind of get that like
the stuff that at three ever you knew I
was a [ __ ] but my brother said to my dad
and I found this out recently that like
but he said that yeah I would have sold
my ass for candy
he wasn't wrong I loved candy and I had
very little regard to - so so are you
terrified then when you're 11 and you're
in Iran and you're kind of putting the
pieces together and you see that this is
how just when reality is people treat
gay people this way are you going like
holy [ __ ] what am I gonna do with this
well I at the time like it wasn't it
wasn't even a gay question it was more
that like you know I was kind I was kind
of more of a [ __ ] like I was just kind
of girlier we called theatrical writer
effervescent um and there was this kid
who was really like clearly trans do you
know what I mean like if whether or not
you believe in it at all when you see
someone who is just so the other gender
as kids you're kind of like well I guess
like sometimes it might happen and uh
that she was I have to call her a she
was a boy but like he was so delicate
and he used to carry pictures of like
the Shahs wife and be like isn't she
beautiful look like this kid was [ __ ]
and they beat the [ __ ] out of this kid
like they beat him rotten you know so
yeah that was the scary part was like if
I if like you know but for one more you
know walking my mom's high heels there
go I you know what I'm right right so
now let me not be the [ __ ] I can't be
that [ __ ] I can't ever if I cross that
line if we're on that kind of rooty
tooty fresh and fruity I'm out I don't
wanna be that obvious you can't lucky
for you that young gentleman has set the
bar so far into [ __ ] Doumbia that you
can get away with a lot and that man is
now our Vice President I'm telling he he
ran with Trump and yes come here no I
did honestly I have no idea I had to get
out of there
the iran-iraq war that was when my
parents decided to go back was the
height in the iran-iraq war that was it
was the stupidest imaginable time to go
back and so we were there Saddam Hussein
took over our radio he pirated our radio
said he was gonna bomb schools and
hospitals every morning at 6:00 in the
morning
and he held true to that he did yeah if
there was literally my elementary school
wasn't what it was it abutted is that
the word a hospital so we hit both with
mom did now is there still ill feelings
towards Saddam in Iran when he was going
down I was just like who do you think
hates this guy more me or any bush lover
do you know what I mean like who do you
think like I hate this guy with my whole
so and I have reason to it's not like
propagandist like fake oil reasons it's
like this guy took over our radio and
bombed my school when I was nine right
you know what I'd be like I legit hate
this guy where's the rest of us were
just like yeah 9/11 yeah right right and
then like oh they they hit the towers
right right yeah right so what you did
you come back to the states after when
you were 11 yeah and then 11 I had to go
to Turkey do my own like my own
immigration work and then come back to
the States
so holiness came out 15 all 14 okay 15
was when I came out but like you know
and then I didn't even act on it till I
was 18
no 17 17 I made out with that kid Josh
who later became like a Jewish pop star
is that right mm-hmm
where'd you make out with him in a hotel
toilet I've been blown in a hotel
bathroom before have you yeah by the
girl she was she was it was she was
gonna get married and rich Voss went in
with her first oh I made out with her
and this is Trinity and then he's like
you made out with her and he goes she
ate my ass but she ate his ass before
yes and then I made out with her after
ID because the one that I was out in the
other room with wanted nothing to do
with Lisa we both went with this one
broad better brighter ever she was she
went ass to mouth except with Voss's ass
in your mouth yes and yeah yeah and then
she sucked my dick she was sit in a
toilet I made out with her she was cute
was she getting she you don't remember
she was getting married I think she
might have been the Bachelorette I don't
remember exactly it's been years 15 you
didn't care
[ __ ] mr. lovestruck and lonely yeah I
don't know too many women who like go
straight for a see a lot of them do you
be surprised like in a toilet with rich
Voss yeah I mean I guess it was more
pleasant look out in his face so then do
you stop here does your relation
ship with your parents become strained
at fifteen or was it had already been
strained right I said had already been
strained and then that was just sort of
like and then I didn't but that's what I
mean there's no so when you're getting
back from that when your dad is like you
should maybe kill yourself you're going
like yeah I kind of figured you'd do
something shitty like that no I was
devastated like I'm not even gonna paint
like you know oh I was over and I wasn't
an over at kid I'm probably still not an
over at adult I mean like it [ __ ]
hurt mm-hmm yeah I was crawling out of
that room with Richards in my pockets
like I was a mess right uh but yeah and
then he died and then I felt better
and that the years freaked him again
yeah I tried I tried having a
relationship with him until the bitter
end like this is just like a sad story
that gets sadder and sadder and sadder
what he's gonna dies he's gonna be
bummed out cuz clearly every time you
talk to him he finds out that you don't
listen to him well and then I'm gonna
rat on him on a national scale I would
like for the rest of my life I'm right
Arnaz name it's bizarre don't you wish
you could see it
mmm I'm sure I'm sure he could predict
it do you talk to your mom you ever say
sure sure you ever go like mom you know
this is what dad said to me sure sure
oh no she was that the whole family was
in cahoots right she's actually she was
like a IU's right yeah like it was just
like we you know we told you to say
something you had to do something you
were going to sell your ass for candy
right like that was the general belief
and it's true and I did sell my ass for
candy like they weren't you should see
what I'm wearing like a III ended up
being a raver taking that like I was
like a future problem child you were
everything they were worried about yeah
absolutely but like there's no resisting
it do you know what I mean you just want
to give it a safe place to land right
right that's right so you're not gonna
change how did you get was the guy you
know is the guy gay who you wanted
kissing or no no no the next day he
ended up like we were at a choral
retreat and then the next day he fell
for a girl and left me like I thought
like we were gonna get married I was
like oh I just like made out with my
husband in a hotel toilet right and then
and then the next day he was with a girl
Wow my heart broke my heart and that's a
bit his first dude you're making out
with that's a big step yeah yeah yeah
and like my parents had made me swear I
wouldn't do anything until I was 18 I
[ __ ] I was just under 18
when you were so like this is it and it
was a one and it felt so wrong I'm in
this hotel toilet yeah I mean like every
girl I had ever made out with it was
like a bit of a chore it was a bit of
like you know a floor routine it was
very gymnastic but here this was the
most natural right thing in the entire
world and then boo and then the next day
he fell he's a pop star kinda yeah I
wasn't no don't you I mean like there's
a part of me that wants to burn him but
like he was only 15 yeah and it would it
be a bit no no we were 17 but yeah 17
would it be a big deal I mean you know I
imagine because he can't he does the
religious circuit oh boy Oh probably
would be a big deal I don't know what
this man is talking about it never
happened I don't even use the bathroom
in hotel I never have do you still talk
to him no no no he like he wouldn't take
my calls after well yeah I mean ya know
it's a shame no no I went full psycho
you did next day that he went with this
girl I was like my minions like I've
sicked the world where you told people
about it oh yeah the one who scorns like
that's the great thing about being out
is that now you can like you know it's
not you're not playing with sequins are
playing with actual life right and I'm
right right yes and so yeah I sick the
world on them I was like look at what
these [ __ ] do you know 200 coral kids
who are just like you [ __ ] deny it
III don't even know that I mean he
didn't have any who's with a girl I
don't know there it never ever became a
question of denied there was no denial
because it was just people shouting at
ya there's no conversation right and now
I live in Israel and I'm sure he's it's
the same but you decided not to keep it
a secret
but not here you wanted people to know
back then too for sure yeah I was so
hurt right well let me play out my hurt
narrative which like at the time they
used to call me scarf boy because I wore
many many scarves and so you gave up on
that whole not being the [ __ ] thing
once you got it it's gone it's gone
I just our boy didn't wear a fake fur
coat here today I'm not wearing pointy
which shoes I'm not I'm not a [ __ ]
anymore dad
anymore that is that is a very it's a
black and white and gray a very uh is it
real furs it folks definitely fake fur
faux fur yeah yeah yeah because I'm
green just kidding I would I would eat
the animal that I would eat it then
where its raw my back no it's fake fur
because you don't happen like this so
then you move on and you become a drug
user rave kid yeah
which saved me saved my life ha ha I
think psychotropics are going are like
the right way to reset a totally broken
soul like I think the right wing could
would do well with like a good asset or
ayahuasca or did you know that ayahuasca
I can't do it but I mean there's some
fighter was talking about it next I
don't dude I've been in recovery I just
can't I don't trust myself is plant
medicine and really you don't it's not
the kind of thing where you do it and
you're like I want to do blow it's not
now I know but I'm a tonight I know I
know you I'm a problem I'm a little
douche we should we should do it yeah I
think we should do it we're going on a
retreat I'll go with you it is March
really nice it is plant based medication
ok Troy you know what let's go to the
voice of reason Troy do you think it's a
good idea or bad I think it's a great
open a lot of boxes you do I mean that's
like literally the sky unzipped and like
a like a mother insect came out who was
made out of like a million digital tiles
yeah yeah it was like when I when I like
a female spirit phalanx of of chips does
surgery on you you take it seriously do
you think that do you think that that's
one of the reasons why you you own your
lifestyle the way you do you kind of
announce it to the world is because
whatever the first 18 years of your life
it's your parents kind of and everything
around you when you're living in Iran
and everything letting you know this is
wrong this is wrong this is wrong the
minute you get away from that you're
like this is right
I really respect what you're saying but
I think with in my case it was that like
I was only like a quarter note away from
being that like dainty girl
mhm boy in Iran like because I'm did you
wanna get your ass kicked like well it's
it's just that I've always been this
this
Rudy and I've always been this outgoing
and I've always dressed like when I was
a little kid I would only wear sherbet
colors and like refused to leave the
house if I couldn't you know it's like
is there a big market for sherbert
colored boys clothing in Iran I mean
like which is why I get to shop off the
sale rack no one's buying this but
that's what this is just you I'd always
been you know I swear to God every night
there was never like a another option
you know what I mean I totally when I
was like a super alcoholic like when I
drank like to scare people I went
through like almost like a militaristic
butch phase but then as soon as that
left my system I was like back to like
tiptoeing through the tulips but that's
it so I had a brief butch phase you did
yeah that was alcohol fueled sure did
you have a lot of aggressive
interactions in bars yeah I was a
bartender I was like a featured
bartender I was me and this Australian
prostitute who taught me how to drink we
were in the paper in Miami and we would
out drink our bar four nights a week
what is a featured bartender so we come
drink with mirin and and I won't say her
because she didn't shine up for this but
uh oh come in Pia and uh and we would go
there and we and anyone who would come
to our bar if they had a shot we had a
shot ice and that's for the whole bar oh
my god a mind eraser we had a mind
eraser and we would drink that much four
nights a week and then in the morning we
would go to another bar and drink until
noon after we closed our bar Wow
yeah I mean it was it was like marathon
Athletic drinking yeah yeah not a vomit
no wonderin mmm I would what I became
amazing at was riding my bike and just
puking while I was I became amazing at
that like do to do to do and like not
miss a pedal so you get the angle right
so that when the wind hits it it's not
hitting you on the side I was a
professional I'm sure just go with one
hand vomit yeah yeah and keep going okay
my car get up no problem but you'd
probably drink past any hangover - well
I mean like I remember that like one day
a week I would order two pizzas and sit
my computer and shake sure and listen to
one album over and over again and just
eat right that was the way my body was
able to survive that pretty healthy
well album would you listen to
realistically Stevie Nicks trouble in
shangri-la look if I'm telling you the
true core that's the record which was
about like a breakup because I had been
with this guy who had a dick like a bit
like it would like a teenager's arm do
you know what I mean like Wow ridiculous
it was why I moved to Miami your your
preference is that make it hard so I
said make it hard to replace him yeah I
mean even even in my mind you know what
I mean it was just his crackling
amethyst and if we probably only grown
in your mind no no no you can't
exaggerate this thing what was it was
the one you prefer a bigger penis on a
man no at the tender age of 42 I'll tell
you and it's like the the [ __ ] isn't
what it used to be kids in my 20s it was
elastic pretty you know what I mean yeah
II like Korean girls skin beautiful and
now it's just mangled it looks like
right the underside of an elementary
school desk lot of mileage initials yeah
it's been vandalized and and there and
it's just not as permeable as it used to
be used to you know right usually just
be uh like a polka but like there's some
you know animated monsters that can take
huge amounts of what happened to the guy
he the worst person in the entire world
I moved for the worst person in the
entire world when you've got a dick like
that you tend to be the worst person I
imagine having a giant dick makes you a
shitty person why would you have to be
why would you work on being a good
person if you're like but my dick though
this is the truth right we're getting
there
we're get we we are so close to telling
America the truth yeah yeah I feel like
a giant dicks are giant dicks if you've
got a dick that's big enough that Mehran
is coming in here yeah what is it 15 20
years later yeah shocked still shocked
oh wait I saw this is the dick of a
lifetime hmm why would you ever learn to
treat people well I don't know that it's
the dick of a lifetime
really yeah that being said even though
it's the more like the most impressive
member I've seen you know what I mean
Rasputin like even though I don't know
that it's it's for a lifetime you know I
see some some giant dicks are for a
season in fact I would say most giant
dicks how
did you date for on and off
year-and-a-half okay on enough
year-and-a-half they say dicks in your
life four seasons I think season those
dicks right right your love I don't have
to walk away from one heel to the other
yeah that's how that's how I left him
yeah no it was it what it wasn't it was
he was a garbage human being oh yeah
really like an actual terrible terrible
person yeah so at what point do you get
into comedy so then I'm working at
Harvard for some year I like leave
bartending because I'm like this is
unsustainable I will drink myself to
death yes so then I started working at
Harvard as a temp
doing what licking envelopes literally
licking freshmen year grades Wow sent
out to the parents but it sounds very
impressive to be like I work at Harvard
yes sure why I grew up mostly in the
Boston area so I was back there my
brother started having babies all over
the place I had to go back to Boston I
feel like to have some semblance of like
an uncle II rolling in my head I was
like that's like my connection to my
family is this next generation they'll
realize how [ __ ] up they were and like
I'll have these nieces and nephews who
get it right wrong tiny Republicans you
don't have that much in common with your
nieces and nephews like not really and
so still the black sheep yeah absolutely
and like they've had this narrative
about like they're crazy druggie uncle
who ruined this family you know what I
mean is the gayness or that worthy or
the drugs that freaks him out well it
started with the game you know it's in
general it's like you know he just won't
do as he's told he could have settled
down and been a lawyer and married a
pretty snow-white looking girl and
instead here he is like sucking dicks
and doing lines Guyana are you still a
recreational drug user sure absolutely
okay absolutely but recreational do you
know what I mean it's like it doesn't
enter the dark zone when it stops being
fun we stopped doing drugs right right
kids so there was a Nancy Reagan oh it
is yeah so then um so you get into
comedy you get into comedy because I
started working at Harvard and then this
one manager was like what do you think
the people who work here I told her
exactly what I thought he thought she
thought that uh that I had good insights
and took me all the way to the top and
the next thing I know I was the project
manager for the office of the president
under Larry Summers the former secretary
of the Treasury under Clinton so I was
writing did you go to college no I'm a
college dropout I see today did the
people at Harvard like when you get to
that level did they realize that the
only reason you were there is because
you were chased out of Miami by a giant
penis I never came to that but that's
the truth yeah yeah and then he got
fired he got chased out of Harvard so he
resigned I'm in Newsweek I'm one of four
people who walked about what he resided
as a college dropout who's doing all
this and then I went to the Harvard
School of Public Health after because my
boss went back there and within one year
George W Bush cut public health funding
so my department saw huge cuts there was
no reason to keep paying for me to be
there it was such a made-up job and I
was unemployed and when I was looking at
more jobs I was like I would sooner kill
myself than go back to higher education
administration and then your dad would
have been proud my dad my family loved
me for like like a year and a hat like
I'm in yourself no but they liked me
what I worked at Harvard sure and then I
just couldn't possibly go back to comedy
so I became a comedian you could go back
to Harvard yeah Harvard Wow so it's
later in life that you became a comedian
I got it no I mean it's still 12 years
ago
let's go isn't it great to be in a job
where like you know none of the comics
like no one care like that in a good way
like yeah you mean about lifestyles yeah
like it's like fine whatever good right
if can you make it funny yeah all right
we're good the most important thing that
I mean like you know I raving was like
it was a huge deal for me because I
found a group of people that have like
sort of like mind like a bunch of broken
children who were taking drugs and
partying together to kind of like what
kind of pants did you wear when you were
raving stovepipe like you know I'm UFOs
Oh Jenkins a man
J goes in UFOs and like you know
eventually I was friends with like
fashion designers and kids who knew how
to sew so they were making me my my your
own custom janko's in UFO which I still
have a few pairs like showed oh do they
have do they have giant bottom like the
Belmont absolutely except except it's
not just the bell bottom it's the whole
life yeah yeah yeah and I'd wear them
with like six and stacks and like party
and liked it when I would take my shoes
off I would be out of dance for like
three days on math Jill have you seen
UFO cargo pants I have not seen the UFOs
I'm familiar you know Jake I said you
know what honestly chips should consider
investing in a pair of UFOs for the next
let me see what your go to the [ __ ]
[ __ ] they're like nylon cargo pants
except there's like straps that hang
down off of them and the bright colors
go to evidence were the ones I had yeah
like that's those are UFO would you wear
those ah probably not the pink I mean I
cared about being hot I did care about
being hot because I was like I needed to
make up for lost time I mean like 90% of
why rape was like I lost a bunch of
weight I was you know I was looking good
I was dancing I'm around all these sort
of like cute straight boys were on
ecstasy so it's like their night off
you know right so for me it was about
looking cute and kind of selling
straight a little bit did you now did
you ever meet did you ever meet a guy
who might not be gay he might have been
straight and then just taking me
somewhere in suck his penis like it
wasn't it wasn't that me to II like you
know what I'd be like it was it's
consensual
yeah least make out with them on the
dance floor before right that's not if
he's guys getting blind uh sent me to if
the guys getting blown that's you just
letting you blow him it'll you gets tiny
somebody from blowing you sure yeah like
what other people think about in terms
of like their gender and their sexual
orientation it's never my problem right
you're just saying hey that's their
that's their narrative that's amazing I
just want to hear the sound of nylon
UFOs on the floor cuz he's kneeling down
blowing a guy who's just there with his
girl
a guy in his [ __ ] football jersey
football sweater she's having a bad trip
because you can't find him yeah I know I
know what are you gonna do I know it was
like two hours tops
they ever be with their girlfriends what
do you mean like at the dance you wanna
go to this dance stop at the cotillion
yeah they were they were often there
with their girlfriends yeah but
sometimes you would perform oral sex on
them
well I more or we would just get naked
and be disgusting because nobody could
get a boner on all the drugs we were on
I see so you just be rubbing flaccid
penises yeah whatever
oh and his girlfriend was just right
outside the bathroom yes still smoking
like I love you guys in the frottage
when I was in high school but in the
hallway I would like bump girls asses
with the back of my hand like just the
girl I didn't know there was a term for
cold front is that what that is it is
yeah it's when you we call I called it
grazing and my buddy would always ask
did you do any grazing today I'll be
like yeah and I would tell her what
girls I got but the feel of a double
cheek er getting a cheek crack in the
cheek was like that when I was 14 that
was [ __ ] everything that's called
frottage yeah it's a fetish I just go
home and jerk off remembering it you
would yeah there's no internet porn no
no see you did perform a little bit of
Friday's you had to remember the girls
hiney it bumped into ya in the locker
room for that I mean I would just sit
there like you know when other people
are like tying their shoelaces like
staring to I would sit on the bench and
then just be in DIC world like if it
were a Mario level it would be DIC world
right you should be sitting there being
like this is great I go in the locker
room change for gym but really I get to
look at all these dicks for a while yes
you loved that yes boss did your quest
airing in a penis and scolded no because
they weren't I mean like I'm sure they
were nervous about her or they just took
it for granted that I was doing it right
you know what I mean because I again I
like you could see me from space in
terms of how how gay it was your
sexuality wasn't a secret it could never
had the luxury of being a secret it
never had the luggage I see I see you
didn't ever did you ever date a girl
that was like oh I thought you were met
meant to be if you oh you will find
women especially with like young mmm no
like they want to believe that you're
not gay you're just sweet like there's
always the girl who date's the obviously
gay guy in high school best articulate
right I wouldn't the hairs always
correct
- why what Wells good other guys there
was though there was this kid in high
school he was in like the drama club and
everything but he was clearly a
homosexual like it was very obvious he
looked like a woman like he was clearly
a homosexual but he wasn't out of the
closet because it was still you know the
late 90s and people weren't coming out
of the closet quite as much even then
and all the girls had crushes on him
because he was nice and had the same
interest and would hang out with them
and we go around and we'd be like he's
gay the guy that you have a crush on his
game and the girls would be like you got
such [ __ ] dicks you guys are [ __ ]
you're just jealous but you said you
just have to sit there and wait thank
God for Facebook cuz you just sit there
and you wait and you wait and eventually
sometimes it's not until the mid-20s
that status changes in you go I told you
yes this was obvious hundred percent and
isn't that why we should be pushing for
a more open world yeah that kid had the
luxury of being gay right then he could
have been your wingman and I think
wingman to every straight buddy I've
ever had where like if they were in love
with a girl I like I don't have friends
who were like utter trash do you know
what I mean and a girl would be like I
don't know if I should I'd be like [ __ ]
you should yeah you should get get your
pipes cleaned and [ __ ] have fun with
this okay he's a good guy and immature
and they would trust your judgment
absolutely they run us so much fun he
wouldn't even leave me astray and I'm
telling you I don't write lead them
astray it's like why can't sex just
[ __ ] happen why can't the sex just
happened how many times I've had that
argument it sounds good in here but it
doesn't happen because you never want to
be your own broker imagine if I could be
your broker and that actually hit this
extra stat gym is usually holding his
own flaccid penis going I'm just [ __ ]
[ __ ] sortie Sai Alice with a mirror
that happens to gays - sucks yes
that's amazing so when you start comedy
you take to it like a fish to water did
you know professor yeah yeah and you
knew this is like this is what I should
have been doing all along I mean I
studied theatre
I was always the class clown I was
always an idiot for my friends I've
always been the and like kind of comic
comedic entertainer and then and then
but I thought that stand-up was
something but like cuz Janine was I was
a huge fan of Janine when I was a kid
she taught me so much about like you
didn't read the porn star Janeane
Garofalo Garofalo it's not not the porn
star although she is also an idol yeah
but I just thought that you opened your
mouth and you sounded like that right
that it was just like a natural language
that you either had like the ability to
comedy or you didn't have the ability to
comedy I didn't understand it as a
process of writing at all alright if you
do actually I think it is something you
have the ability to do some people I've
worked really hard they just have no
ability like I have known people yeah
they want to be funny so but it's the
saddest thing somebody who desperately
wants to be funny and just isn't yeah
I've heard a lot of people like that in
my life and it's a weird thing to watch
like they want to be they want to
understand what that just that natural
comfortable funny thing is and they will
never know it for as long as they live
and it's frustrating to watch for them I
feel frustrated for them mm-hmm yeah
there's that's a no bruh I mean we were
kind of talking about this when we were
doing the documentaries like how when
you start as a comedian you're Wiz like
this pool of people that's like you know
probably you know 600 people in your
hometown or like whatever city you're
starting in or maybe 200 300 people and
then you know little by little you stop
working with those people as you move up
the ladder and you don't it's just a
weird thing but like I I look back on
those days super nostalgic ly like I
miss getting to work with people who are
just trying to be funny I guess I
remember when my one friend when I was
due I was really early understanding but
he would come like the first couple
years and he would do open mics and he
just
it would just be jokes you know it was
they were always not good it was you
know they were bad and there's no time
being no ability and he didn't just
strike you as a naturally funny person
oh it's never good no they wanted it you
just want community go get community
right there sure
I stink it improv by the way onstage in
a comedic you know I could have told you
someone who can't yeah I get it problem
easily but not like like it when improv
people do it is real skilled to it and
I've said this many times like I can't I
have no ability to run up in a scene and
I just I make it dirty fast I don't obey
the rules I'm just I panic yeah yeah
have you seen that bus no it's a toaster
exactly doesn't help me I saw the bust
aids dick [ __ ] predictable three [ __ ]
ha joke's aids dick [ __ ] right I have no
ability just to go with the scene and
like I I admire it I think if you can do
it right but I mean like and the ones
who end up doing it like they practice
and comedy you know stand-up you
practice yeah get better at it they take
these classes with groups that's the
things that they don't have the luxury
of getting better on their own they have
to that's right you know which means
that you have to run around with improv
people and Jesus Christ I mean you know
what I mean even I say there's some [ __ ]
even I won't put in my mouth you know
what I mean and it's a yes and yes and
your balls get out